für die fragen besprechen alle zusammen
und heute werden wir ausführlich
sprechen aber zuerst wollte ich die
frage besprechen wie wir vorige woche
besprochen haben heute habe ich ein
erlass unterschrieben dass die regeln
des handels mit dem russischen natur gas
festlegt mit sogenannten unfreundlichen
statten wir schlagen den kontrahenten
aus diesen staaten ein verständliches
transparentes schema vor um das
russische gas zu erwerben müssen sie
rubel konnten in russischen banken
eröffnen erst vor diesen konnten wird
die bezahlung von gas durchgeführt dass
das was vom ersten april dieses jahres
ab morgen durchgeführt wenn solche
zahlungen nicht stattfinden werden wir
das als nicht erfüllung der pflichten
seitens des käufers betrachten mit allen
daraus folgenden folgen keine verkauft
uns etwas
kostenlos und wir wollen auch keine
wohltätigkeit betreiben das heißt die
die unser verträge werden eingestellt
das heißt das bremssystem als das
westlichen staaten als waffe benutzt
wird wenn die unternehmen aus diesen
staaten verzichten konnten verträge zu
erfüllen aus banken mit natürlichen
personen werden sie aktiv was in euro
und dollar eingefroren werden hat es
keinen sinn die währungen dieser staaten
zu benutzen in wirklichkeit was passiert
wir haben den europäischen konsumenten
unsere ressourcen geliefert in diesem
fall geht es um gast die haben das auch
bekommen haben mit euro bezahlt und
selbst dann auch eingefroren es gibt
alle gründe zu betrachten dass ein teil
des gelieferten gas nach europa wie
praktisch
unentgeltlich geliefert haben so kann es
natürlich nicht weitergehen zumal im
falle der weiteren lieferungen und
bezahlung nach der tradition schema die
neuen finanz
lieferungen in dollar oder
euro auch blockiert werden können eine
dieser entwicklung der situation ist zu
erwarten zumal wenn manche politiker im
westen wir reden darüber öffentlich eben
gerade in diesem sinne äußern sich die
regierungschefs der europäischen union
die risiken der jetzige sachlage ist
nicht annehmbar und wenn wir im komplex
die ganze sache betrachten dann die die
über über umstellung der bezahlung
russische rubel ist ein wichtiger
schritt zur festigung unser
wirtschaftliches überlegt wir wirken
auch weiter konsequent
systematisch uns in diese richtung uns
bewegen im rahmen des langfristigen
plans wir werden die mängel der
abrechnungen in nationalen währenden
erweitern und auch in währungen der
starten die freundschaftlich sind ich
habe es viele lieferanten auf das
sprechen auch über die diversifizierung
der devisen abrechnungen ich wiederhole
russland legt wert auf die eigene
hoch und wir erfüllen alle verträge
einschließlich auch gasverträgen wir
werden gas in den festgelegten umfängen
die in festgelegten umfänge betone ich
und auch nach preisen die festgelegt
wurden in den langfristigen verträgen
ich betone diese preise sind viel viel
niedriger als die jetzigen notierungen
auf den internationalen märkten was
bedeutet das dass russisches gas ist
viel billigere energie wärme und licht
in den häusern der europäer und die auch
zugänglicher preis für für auch dünger
und auch lebensmittel und das geht dabei
um die konkurrenzfähigkeit
europäischen unternehmen und das heißt
auch die gehälter der bürger der
europäischen stadt aber wenn man die
erklärungen manche politiker betrachtet
wollen sie verachten diese interessen
der eigenen bürgern und dem dem
sozusagen
heraus der hinter dem ozean sozusagen
gut zu tun das heißt der populismus
geschlagene vor weniger zu essen und
sparen für heizung und alles weniger
reisen nur zu güte der menschen die das
nun sozusagen wegen der abstrakten
nordatlantischen solidarität solche
zweifel hatte handlungen in der
politischen
lebensmittelpolitik beobachten wir auch
nicht zum erster nach der
lebensmittelkrise folgt noch ein krise
es wird auch noch eine krise in der
europäischen union aber dennoch schritt
für schritt werden entscheidungen
getroffen die die weltwirtschaft zu
krise führen das geht so zerstörung der
logistik verbindungen zur
reduzierung des wohlstandes millionen
von menschen und zur zerstörung der
integration in vielen ländern auch zu
tragödien des massen hungers natürlich
es entsteht die frage wer trägt dafür
die verantwortung wer wird dafür die
verantwortung trage es ist klar die
vereinigten staaten werden versuchen die
eigenen probleme zu lösen eben gerade
die eigen auf große anderen die werden
neue welle der emission und
budgetdefizit in gang setzen es ist auch
jetzt sehr hoch und die führenden
europäischen
wirtschaften die inflations schlägt
rekorde und auch in vereinigten staaten
und dabei die eigenen fehler in der
wirtschaftspolitik
versuchen sie auf uns abzuschieben sie
suchen immer denn
sündenbock stellen schuldigen und das
ist offensichtlich usa werden auch noch
versuchen zu verdienen an der jetzige
global instabilität wie sie das während
des ersten und des zweiten weltkrieges
geführt haben und während der eigenen
aggression gegen irak syrien
jugoslawien usw die globale märkte
fallen aber aber die kosten der
menge geld die kapitale verschwinden und
aus der gleichen sind auch die
ich suche europa auf die auf das teure
amerikanische gas- umzustellen so lässt
man die amerikaner nicht nur mehr geld
zu bezahlen aber zugleich versucht man
die konkurrenzfähigkeit europäischen
unternehmen zu
sprengen und sie vom max und wenn das
bedeutet die den
industrialisierungsprozess
und wenn man bedenkt dass die preise
steigen für lebensmittel brennstoffe und
auch und das ist auch reduzierung das
lebensniveau eben das ist der preis den
die westlichen eliten zwischen menschen
zu zahlen für deren emissionen und die
für nicht
durchdachten aktionen zugleich auch für
den
wirtschaftskrieg denn sie versuchen
gegen russland zu entfesseln und ich
würde sagen sogar schon entfesselt haben
dieser krieg begann nicht in den letzten
monat und die legitimen sanktionen
wurden ständig seit vielen jahren
eingeführt das ziel dieser aktion ist
die entwicklung russlands zu reduzieren
und potenzial in der wirtschaft in der
produktion zu unterminieren ich
wiederhole diese sanktionen wurden von
vornherein vorbereitet man hätte sie so
oder so eingeführt ich bekomme das ist
im grunde eine sanktion für unser recht
auf freiheit auf das recht unabhängig zu
sein auf das recht russland zu sein da
wir wollen nicht unter die für fremde
pfeife tanzen die wollen nicht unser
nationalen interessen und traditionelle
werte preisgeben der kollektive besten
beantwortet das
möchte nicht auf diese politik
verzichten mehr noch natürlich es wird
wird immer der westen wird neue mit nun
neue gründe und vorwände zu sanktionen
suchen deshalb können wir nicht damit
rechnen dass das sich ändert und deshalb
bitte ich die regierungsbank russland
subjekte der redaktion wenn sie bei der
entwicklung der wirtschaft für sich
darauf zu orientieren das die sanktions
druck auf unser land so wie auch in
früheren jahrzehnten behalt erhalten
bleibt das ist die objektive realität
was finde ich wichtig zu betonen und ich
bitte alle drauf aufmerksam zu machen
wenn wir die situation in jedem
einzelnen bereich in jedem einzelnen
branche betrachten müssen wir nicht nur
uns darauf zu richten dass wir nur die
hindernisse des letzten jahres sondern
wir müssen auch unser pläne bauern auf
der grundlage der innerstaatlichen
möglichkeiten auch auf unsere eigene
entwicklung der wissenschaft und wir
müssen auf die private initiative und
gesunden wettbewerb uns gründe wir
müssen anstreben dass unsere unternehmen
maximal belastet wird und dass die
konkurrenzfähigkeit russlands insgesamt
global gestärkt wird und die schlüssel
zeigen der effizienz unserer
wirtschaftspolitik bleibt die erhaltung
und schaffung von arbeitsplätzen
reduzierung der armut erhöhung dass
lebensqualität und die auf
zugänglichkeit von waren und
dienstleistungen eben unter der
berücksichtigung dieser moment da haben
wir im letzten in der letzten woche
unsere situation im bauwesen besprochen
und heute sprechen wir über über
luftfahrtindustrie diese industrie
spielt eine wichtige rolle in der
entwicklung der russischen wirtschaft
und dass diese branche hat eine wichtige
bedeutung für
verkehrssituation für die verbindung
zwischen unseren
regionen ich möchte ihnen gerufen dass
die russischen luftfahrtindustrie
besonders als erster die nicht adäquaten
entscheidungen der westlichen
unternehmen verspürt die haben irgendwie
westlichen haben in der letzten woche
verzichtet die verträge zu erfüllen im
bereich der luftfahrt ihm wissen sie
haben betrogen die partner in dem sie
aufgehört haben die lieferung von
leasing von von versicherung gesagt ich
werde ich werde weil seite schieben die
konsequenzen für die eigenen unternehmen
der westliche industrie aber ich möchte
sagen dass die russischen unternehmen
die verträge in vollem umfang erfüllt
haben uns immer waren bereit auch weiter
diese verträge zu erfüllen aber die
westlichen seite hat ihren schritt
unternommen und wir werden natürlich
auch den diesen schritt beantworten also
der frühere zusammenarbeit mit diesen
taten wird das nicht geben in der
nächsten zeit wir haben nicht vor was
ich zu verschließen und wie würde kein
geschlossenes land sein aber wir müssen
aus den realitäten ausgehende wir haben
wir haben alle möglichkeit damit
luftfahrtindustrie nicht nur die
herzigen schwierigkeiten überwinden
sondern auch neuen impuls zur weiteren
entwicklung bekommen in erster linie
müssen wir unsere luftfahrt unternehmen
unterstützen damit deren ständige
rhythmische tätigkeit weiter
im gange bleibt und dass für die bürger
russlands die luftfahrt reisen
zugänglich werden das sind die jetzigen
aufgaben was die langfristigen aufgaben
sind wir müssen die entwicklung der
luftfahrtindustrie korrekt ihren unter
der berücksichtigung der eigenen
ressourcen unter neuen bedingungen
wir haben die wir haben möglichkeiten
für unsere lieferanten von
bestandteilen für
konstruktionsbüro in den nächsten
dutzend jahre muss die anzahl der
inländischen flugzeuge für die
luftfahrtindustrie steigen und das ist
natürlich eine chance für die
produzenten der
luftfahrttechnik und natürlich soll auch
dabei die sicherheit und wirtschaftliche
effizienz
gesteigert das ist wichtig auch für
russische unternehmen sie müssen sich
als dynamisches und
einnahme fähiger business entwickeln
damit die bürger die
flugtickets zum zugänglichen preis gang
und dass der service und die den
modernsten stand daten entsprechend und
ich spreche dabei nicht nur in der
regionalen flügen sondern auch insgesamt
über die spreche ich die entwicklung der
mit der verbindung mit den entfernten
region wir unsere industrie muss eine
ganze reihe von inländischen flugzeuge
entwickeln und dabei die technische
bedienung und reparatur der luftfahrt
schiffer dem entspricht dem und wir
müssen jetzt anfangen zu arbeiten
ich teile das wort gleich wieder
meine damen und herren das war die
position und der blick des russischen
präsidenten wladimir putin wir haben ihn
gesehen in einer videoschaltung friends
mit vertretern der russischen wirtschaft
das war ja angekündigt worden dass es
möglicherweise zwei termine gibt gut
möglich dass sozusagen auch ein gewisser
mix stattgefunden hat auf jeden fall
sollten an diesen gesprächen teilnehmen
und das ist ja auch adressiert worden